I just finished watching the whole
season last night and I feel like I have
so many questions that I cannot ask
about
um but I would love to start with how
this all began for you because you're
coming off of a show like Supernatural
which had such an impressive run
but then thinking about next steps what
made you want to take on something like
this series as your next project it was
two things it was number one is I'm just
a huge fan of Resident Evil you know
what I mean and the games and the movies
the games we're defining in a way for me
just for the horror genre period
um in terms of like they really form
kind of what I think [ __ ] is and what
really works and you can see that in
Supernatural at different points
um and then you know the movies I think
are a bit underrated because they were
one of the first movies that really took
multiple genres and kind of shovel them
together you know whether it's sci-fi
and horror and action and everything
else so they're really kind of defining
in two different ways so when the
opportunity came about I was like oh I
would love to do that dolor is so
interesting and it was like okay well if
you're gonna do it how can you make it
feel different than kind of what's out
there and luckily Resident Evil itself
has a lot of elements that you can do
that with with the monsters and some of
the backstory and the corporate
maneuverings the crazy conspiracies
um
and then they they kind of allowed us
they being uh Netflix and uh and Capcom
to kind of build on that as well so the
games are the backstory but we kind of
now are kind of you know branching off
into our own little world so I guess
that brings me to my next question what
can you kind of reveal or explain about
the show's timeline for people who are
wondering about where this fits into the
larger Resident Evil Universe sure so
basically everything game wise has been
released uh up to now which is you know
Village
um is our backstory
and from that point the games are gonna
go this direction and we're gonna go
this direction
um and and believe me if the games do
something if we're lucky enough to go
more seasons and the games do something
awesome and like Resident Evil 9 like we
will steal that we will happily steal
that
um but I don't but we're we're not
informing the games Capcom has their own
beautiful plan for where they plan to
take things that's great and then the
movie is kind of are kind of I would say
like an alternate reality you know what
I mean certainly tonally
um staging wise we're certainly inspired
by the movies like I love the movies
um but the Alice character things like
that don't really exist in this world
it's like the Resident Evil Multiverse
it's like there wasn't even multi
exactly the good news is we're all very
familiar with multiverses now so it fits
right in
um what's the biggest challenge that
people might not be aware of when it
comes to tackling a show like this that
is based in existing IEP I think the
biggest thing is a lot of times when
you're dealing with IP you're doing what
I would call like dead IP so it's a
novel that exists or a movie series that
came out 20 years ago Resident Evil has
uh when we were developing it had a
movie it had an animated series it had
another game coming out and us that's
about as alive as IP gets you know what
I mean so you want to do something that
again feels a piece with everything else
but is distinctively its own thing and
doesn't feel like it's not like you
watch the movie and you watch the show
you're like oh that's the same story why
would I watch that again you know what I
mean or you what you watch the show and
you play the games you're like why am I
why am I doing this my hope is that
everything kind of folds into each other
and you watch the show and you'll get it
to the end of it and be like you know
what I really want to go play those
games I really don't want to go watch
the you know Netflix and come up and be
like watch the Resident Evil movie like
I would like to watch that and you watch
it and it feels of a world you know what
I mean so hopeful hope hopefully
everything kind of dovetails together in
a way I feel like when watching this I
mean and you get this sense from the
trailers too but umbrella is
over everything which is fitting
considering the name you know
um but what can you share about this
incarnation of umbrella in the show and
what they've been up to yeah so this I'm
gonna so umbrella you know for most of
its history was essentially a weapons
manufacturer uh for the US government
um that didn't go so great for various
reasons which if you play the games you
know and umbrella now under Evelyn
Marcus you know her father kind of
founded the company it was stolen from
him she's kind of coming and picked up
the pieces and rebuilt umbrella in a
different image one that is a bit more
you know it's like Pfizer or something
along those lines right moderna
but with kind of that old school maybe
questionably ethically questionable DNA
uh so uh so that's the fun of it the fun
of it is I mean you look at it like a
company like you know uh Atari or
whatever that kind of goes down and then
it kind of gets built back up you know
um which by the way is a very old
reference which because Atari no longer
exists but at one point it went through
that cycle you just have to trust me on
that I feel like you can't talk about
Resident Evil without talking about the
monsters they're the creatures and there
are some gnarly ones in this show I I'm
not sure what you can say but what can
you kind of tease so far for fans in
terms of who what I guess what we'll get
to see
yeah I think you know when it comes to
monsters both kind of the zombies and
kind of what we call like super zombies
uh zombies that have a maybe aren't
traditional uh you know guys chasing
brains
um and then and the hybrid creatures as
well what we wanted to do is these are
things that a lot of them have existed
in the games in kind of one form or
another we wanted to put our own twist
on them and also make them kind of feel
like something that exists on you know
streaming today the the visual effects
have gotten so much better
just not just since the movies but like
in the last two years when it comes to
television specifically and streaming
specifically that it was really fun to
kind of bring those things to life and
and hopefully knock on wood we'll get to
continue to do that I feel like the show
I mean it's definitely rooted in the
lore of the games the world of the games
but one of the themes I think that
really struck me watching is the family
that this intimate sense of family you
know family connection but it it's
coming from a surprising Source in
Albert Wesker
um what can you say about the
relationship that he and his daughters
have this season yeah I mean and that's
on purpose you know what we wanted fans
of the games to see Albert like as a
Suburban dad and be like how did that
happen you know what I mean and then we
kind of explore that over the course of
the games
um you know I think his relationship
with his daughters is it's complicated
you know what I mean like they're his
daughters and he loves them but at the
same time like he's a very
um distant father let's put it that way
and I think a lot of parents kind of
view their kids as
again this this this is this is maybe me
projecting too much of my own life
um a means to an end and I think Albert
looks at his daughters in that way a
little bit too you know what I mean like
yes he had them because he wanted kids
but he also had them for a reason with
the show being linked to the franchise
in its own way I would say um are there
any specific franchise characters that
you were hoping to be able to introduce
at some point Beyond who we've met so
far uh all of them that's my hope
um if the show runs long enough uh look
they're certainly you know by the end of
the end of the show we're kind of
teasing characters including Ada Wong
um if we're lucky if you haven't season
two uh I think we can expect multiple
characters from the games to appear
um in ways that are you know kind of
inevitable I think uh and and hopefully
a little bit surprising provided you do
get a season two are we gonna see more
of the Dual timeline kind of the back
and forth between the past and the
present as those Mysteries begin to
unfold yes definitely
on that note I I am all out of time but
thank you so much for your time to sit
and chat with me about the show it's
been great to get to pick your brain a
little and I'm excited for the rest of
the world to to finally get to see it so
me too thank you thank you so much